they were starting to replay and we're
going to be looking at Plato and student
Aristotle for a couple weeks in this
class and you know at first you might
say what does this have to do with
euthanasia or capital punishment or
abortion or things like that you'll see
the connections over time those are not
quite so big hot-button issues for these
people back in ancient Greece as they
carry content but the ways in which they
think about things they provide us a
structure that's a complicated structure
that has been used over and over again
to to think about ethics to think about
what kind of life you want to live
what's where the actions are triggered
bad we're starting to Republic you're
not going to read any of other Plato's
works in this class you're interested in
that sort of thing you know and you talk
to me after class and I'll tell you
where you would read those sort of
things and we're after we behold of a
moment we're just going to read parts of
it and you notice that I've also not
only are we going to read the parts I've
actually given you condensed versions of
the text that have me like usually three
or four pages that you can you can print
out that will focus on particularly in
class because you know how are in
fifteen minutes can we go through an
entire a chapter of a book probably not
not very deeply we want to focus on some
things and we're going to focus on some
things in this class differently than we
would in an intro to philosophy class
where it's more gentlemen this is epic
so we're going to focus really closely
in on certain issues and certain
conversations
I'll do a little bit of introduction
before we do that we're often going to
start our class like this with sort of a
brainstorming exercise and I'm going
somewhere so this is a term that you've
heard your whole life justice when you
hear that what sort of associations what
what comes to mind and anything it is
okay quality beauty cloth
okay very good we often say creative
injustice we have these associations
else maybe a few more things
yeah yeah I know some of you are CJ
majors criminal justice is tied in with
how we enforce the laws to punish people
that's a particular part of Justice
right what else anything else
you feel justice is a good thing a bad
thing you need to feel warm and fuzzy in
here quickly because we just sit back
and kindergarten anybody wanted to treat
it unjustly I could give you a nap even
though you do all the work that wouldn't
be very Johnson right nobody wants that
yeah okay notice that a lot of these are
values in and of themselves that we
connect with justice freedom in choices
treated the same thing as justice no but
they're connected so so I must do the
same thing as justice might be in some
cases it's not exactly the same as
getting whether what is deserved
that's actually gonna be one of the
definitions of justice we're going to
look at today quality that might be
that's not the one that we're actually
going to look at today but that's tied
in with a lot of people's understanding
justice when do you think you started
noticing justice and injustice
high school before that yeah having a
little brother okay how did that come up
there he would city would claim that
everything was not fair you had claim
that everything's not looking back and
we think it really was not fair so you
do have the experience now notice what
we're doing here remember how we talked
last class about McIntyre and playing
persons and theories we've got this big
general concept justice and then in your
life particular America we have a
particular situation you and your
brother and what did you you know what
was on care where the candy bar was
divided in chores or yeah no this is how
we think about justice in the first
place we don't think about justice soon
what is justice let us talk about that
you know the way these guys are at the
beginning of the dialogue they're
actually sitting down we have an
intellectual conversation because these
guys like to have intellectual
conversations we start thinking about
justice or writing long long time before
then when we were little kids we have a
sense of something being violated in
certain circumstances Walken it's tied
into the quality of fairness you know
the kid who the teacher likes the most
gets to candy bars but you only get one
how do you feel what happens what do you
think what do you say honey the hing
imagine you're four years old how did
you because I'm sure something like that
happened to you
what did you say probably cried bed or
y'all showed anger in some way why are
you angry I was in an ok with
because it's not fair right you appeal
to something in a particular
circumstance is something broad or
something Universal and then they would
say they might give you a reason waltz
okay first for a little Johnny to have
two key antivirus because he's my
favorite
yeah and favorites get more you want
more candy bars start acting like my
favorite my vision here response or the
teacher might say oh yeah I shouldn't do
that sort of thing I've better set a
good example for you it takes away a
little Johnny's candy bar or maybe they
want to be punitive fine nobody gets a
candy bar right but these sort of issues
of right not come up for us as very
early kids as soon as we start having
some sort of sense of what's due to
people what would they deserve including
ourselves and what we ought to be giving
to them think back for a moment to your
to your child how far back can you
remember first of all and you can any of
you remember like when you were three
remember when you're four five five a
good cut out did all of you do something
that you shouldn't have done when you
were five but you can think of it at
this time
I remember punching my mom God knows why
I did you know we're just sitting there
and kids have these these sort of come
out of nowhere a sadistic impulses and I
hit her in the arm and she said wow you
know don't do that that's wrong and what
do you think I felt about that how did
you feel when you did something wrong
he's probably did something less drastic
you felt violated something right broke
something if you didn't then probably
something was wrong like if you never
did you've done a lot of bad things and
you don't feel any remorse about it
you're probably a sociopath yeah
you should probably keep that to your
child if people find that out they're
not gonna want to have to anything to do
it right like a sociopath or dangerous
but most of us probably all of us in
this balance have a sense of right and
wrong and it's kind of instinctive and
you know we're often can sloppy about it
we often don't know how to apply it so
let's think for a couple minutes
what are some things that are right just
off the top again what's something you
want to see you show compassion anything
else you can think these are good things
to do you know I'd like to be with
somebody who does these sorts of things
is that what makes it right I like them
well this enough to get by as long as we
talked about there's cultural compassion
then I'll get you through everything
closely you care about what do you let's
say you you are stuck with moving I'm
going to be handling these on the solid
so some of you may have been a good
experience some of you may have a bad
experience how many of you get a good
experience okay what about your roommate
the hater did you did you like or some
things I shouldn't
should why yeah you don't just be taking
things off such a strong I'm gonna steal
okay what else
what's that was a really big
because how many because it be
adequately if you have a bad roommate
only if you well that's kind of good bad
roommate what did they do
decided that they do anything besides
why are taking things without permission
that's a big one for romance right
especially like things in the fridge
present Harmer hopefully they can kill
anybody but also the damper mate
what else should you
my dad does not being considerate okay
without this lower on the scale and
killing somebody but if this little
thing right it's not really much of
response if you say hey you know you're
in the red shirt of somebody Lisa don't
kill somebody
there's no bad what else do you say it's
bad it's interesting if you think about
- the Ten Commandments
shell and like any other religious code
they tend to regulate certain things
stealing is always one of them who can
take what things belongs to so it
doesn't matter whether you're a Jew
Christian was alone Buddhist Hindu
stealing's wrong cosmic power I think
you know it tends to be qualified and
there's some people you can cause harm
to or some situations where you can
other situations where you're not
supposed to right I'm killing someone
every single religion regulates who can
be killed who can't be killed when force
can be used any force being
inconsiderate what do you think that may
fall under that's a big thing all right
you can be consistent consider with your
actions you can also do things with all
that falls on your mind I shall not bear
false
goodness I mean this shouldn't go to
court and swear to tell the truth and
then they don't say so I killed somebody
it's extended that that why you're not
not to lie okay what else gets regularly
it's interesting it doesn't come up in
this class yeah
yeah and now we don't talk about it in
those terms in our popular culture do
events if someone so it's an adulterer
we tend to think of it in terms of
cheating shouldn't girlfriend you're a
committed relationship
you're supposed to be committed and if
you break the commitment the other
person could say here you're on jobs
you're doing the wrong thing good thing
matter of fact they do we have all TV
shows built around that premise the up
TV shows are built around the premise of
catching the person that they have in
that shooter's you notice what do they
do they never contested that cheating is
wrong what do they say oh you're you're
you say in the situation the wrong yeah
I'm not really cheating they don't
usually say cheating isn't a bad thing
there sighs I'm not perfect this is
getting us to where we want to be all
these things are what we call universals
if I say that you should tell the truth
I don't just mean in this classroom at
this time yeah you should tell the truth
so long as you're dr. Sanders at this
class because you know that's what we do
here but once you get outside of the
ethics class anything goes well that
makes sense the way we treat these
things when you're having a conversation
and you feel that somebody has wronged
you and you're trying to bring it to
their attention and you're probably
fighting with them a bit as they usually
how do they you know react to that I
didn't do that here you're full of it
they don't want to hear it and you bring
up something like this we can say you
know you're supposed to tell me the
truth but you lied to me
that applies in other situations too
right
that's why they can turn it around on
you and say and you will have to be last
week it's a universal so it applies
across the war the reason I'm bringing
this up is because that's when it's high
end with this guy through semanas who
were looking at today one we want to get
to later and then there's notion of
justice is just being what's in the
interest of the stronger can using out
the universals like that though I mean
think about what really matters to you
but you know with your greatest values
you know what what matters to other
people tell about the behavior does
everybody see these as reversals or you
know are the sometimes they make
exceptions for size
what was your experience have you ever
made an exception for yourself when came
to my mind was okay in this situation
yeah but you save someone's feeling
that's what real issue that's something
that that ethicists as well as ordinary
people debate a lot about and have
different positions on you know if
somebody says how do I look today and
you know that you know telling them the
honest truth about their appearance
which they're asking you for they're
inviting you to give is going to crush
their ego and they're going to
do poorly in a test that they're taking
which is important for their career is
it the right thing to do to to lie and
say you look great
never better that's a real live issue
and you you know you can try to resolve
that on a situation by situation basis
that's probably not going to be that
successful what you want to do is look
to some sort of universals if there are
exceptions to lying you probably want to
know what those are before you head into
any sort of difficult situation what am
i killing is it ever okay to kill
somebody anybody think that it is okay
sometimes it kills me I need a few more
hands go up when they find out that the
teacher thinks it's okay it's okay if
you think that it's okay to company
people I think so long as you don't
think it's okay to do it for fun you
know just you know there's a weekend
thing how many of you think that it's OK
in some cases to kill me you want to be
able to outline which cases are those
cases don't you you don't want to have
to get into a situation and say well I
think about it yeah in this case it's
okay and then not have any reasons why
and then the next case it is
so these universals really really matter
to us
that's all background to where we're
going to be concerned with this question
what is justice so what I want to do now
for the next couple minutes is just give
you kind of an overview what this text
that I threw in your lap is I'm going to
assume that all of you have read like
the first book of it yeah well why is it
called a book to the adventurer and you
know why these old these old texts are
comic books you think a little republics
the book right did you go out to buy it
before we get books that opened up that
folded it's sort of like like this you
know we had Scrolls and you would
actually read by rolling the scroll down
you can imagine how cumbersome that was
and to carry a blog meant carrying a
bunch of scrolls so the Republic has X
amount of books because it's a certain
amount of length it took ten Scrolls to
hold that book so other other texts may
have six books to ebooks ten books 100
books that's how many Scrolls it would
take so when you see the book look one
distinct chapter one right now book one
you know it's being divided that way not
necessarily because that's where we
should cut things but that was the
length as it turns out there is kind of
some fanatic thing we're going to look
at what - Thursday right that's going to
deal with some
issues concerning concerning justice but
what else to need to know about it's a
major work by this guy plato was one of
his greatest works it's important during
a college career for the unit's have
come in contact with this you may have
already in history class or some sort of
core files have somebody read through
public before what kind of text is so we
call it dialogue where you guys seem
dialogues I know you read a lot of
what kind of dialogues
planners yeah every single plays a diet
cause that's what's going on someone so
says and so and so says and so on so
since Shakespeare is all dialogue on the
elbows to Iowa you go watch TV movies
all dialogue right there's other things
too there's apply the dialogues that
we're looking at with Plato don't have a
plot so the characters aren't talking to
try to make things happen or to do
things they're doing something a bit
different but trying to understand
things they're trying to convince people
of things
so there's think about a play where
nobody actually does anything there
you've got to dial but what they're
doing is is you know sitting in one
place and discussing something it's sort
of like a transcript then if you listen
to NPR on the radio or the shows or you
tune in sometimes to a sports channel
hear the commentators talking and doing
an interview with somebody if you've got
a transcript that would be a dialogue
and that would be some more swords that
they're talking about an issue and
they're not actually trying to do
anything or displaying what the action
is they're talking about some sort of
issue in this case the central issue is
justice what is justice and they're
going to explore this you have about
five main people talking through this
you know Socrates and Socrates was
Plato's teacher in this dialogue we take
Socrates as reference
play those positions as you go and read
through the Republic you're going to see
Socrates going from questioning people
to actually laying out some positions
and in the later books in this park is
actually just questioning them he's
trying to show if there's any problems
with their views who are the other
people there's three young men that that
are named Lofton Anna mantis and polo
markets kind of funny names I know but
you know these are ancient Greece and
they are sort of thinking about them as
sort of upper-class
good character young men who are rising
in the world that are likely to take
little office or conduct some important
business these are the kind of the
movers and shakers and then you've got
this Oh video guy that's your sim
against your sim because as a forum is
not from Athens and through semanas is
10% of calls a sophist the Sophists were
these teachers would go around then and
they would they would say that they
could teach you how to speak well and
that they could teach you all sorts of
other things as well but mostly what
they taught was was rhetoric how to
convince me turned out a lot of the
rhetoric was just like you know appeal
to their emotions or use this this
attractive that tricked and precipitous
sort of exemplifies that if we go beyond
this what else is going on in this disc
which why do we care about this in an
ethics class why is this imaginary
probably imaginary dialogue between
these ancient Greeks matter to us today
when you are going to have real careers
and face real life choices that weren't
even thought about back in ancient
Greece well because what they're doing
is they're laying out different theories
of justice different ways of looking
what's right and what's wrong and those
still are now those are pertinent today
juicy MCUs died back in ancient Greece
for some akiza's ideas we're still alive
today the ideas that Marc and Amanda
mantis and polemarchus those are still
around today Plato's ideas are still
around today that's why we're reading
through this and you'll recognize some
of these these ideas in your own life if
you think about it carefully what we're
going to what we're going to do then if
we start out we're going to ignore a lot
of what's going on at the beginning of
the dialogue at the top of the pie
radius and you know I was with Wow good
and they and they said you have to come
along with us that retort raises we're
gonna figure it all that that that
setting stuff that I was call it blah
blah blah right now it's interesting to
read I don't want to say that it has no
value but as far as what justice is
we're not so interested but we're going
to look at our two main things one is
what we could call sort of conventional
or common sense understanding of justice
and then another one is through Senecas
conception of justice and let's
Thanks right you guys have heard that
saying before right or another way of
putting it to you ask it's we don't say
that quite so often these days but do
you think about it it's not gonna be a
hard thing to relate to so let's look at
these can these sort of conventional
notions of jobs and some of this is in
the condensed text that I gave you these
are selections from the reading and this
guy capitalist leaves catalyst is a
father of Anna mantis and he's not going
to stick around now it's the young men
talking of Socrates and says what about
justice is it to speak the truth and pay
your debts as does that yet those are
just things right speaking the truth we
when we did that listing of right and
wrong you guys came up with that right
away to pay your debts is that important
for being good person Oh imagine some of
you probably have a college that's not
right it won't would it be wrong for you
to say how about I pay those imagine
that you could get away because these
things they don't let you do that
the reason why they they're so tough on
you guys is because so many people
didn't pay their
because they to speak the truth and pay
our debts
are there exceptions of them let's say
paying the debts means giving people
back what you owe them so if I'm under
100 bucks and I say I'm giving this for
a week and you don't give it back to me
after a week or you know you're doing a
bad thing right
you're not necessarily a terrible person
but you're doing something I'm just one
of the [ __ ] he's got a classic example
here what if you give me your gum
and you say I want you to hold on to
this for me it's not hovering I haven't
killed anybody with it I just need you
to hold on to the phone because I can't
keep guns in my dorm room man they don't
let you keep guns on campus right and
now you come to me in the middle of the
night and you bang at my door dr.
Sandler eat my gun and you're just wrong
why do you need your gun Kelso well you
know in one sense I gotta give you the
gun shouldn't I
it's your god they gave it to me with
the idea that I was going to give it
back to you didn't you if I don't give
it to you you're probably gonna say
something like that you said you were
gonna do this you said you're gonna give
it back to me would it be the wrong
thing for me to do why would it be the
wrong thing no mystery here yeah so
there's already there's a problem with
this conventional notion just
and that's getting things back to people
so I said speaking the truth paying your
debts is not a correct definition of
justice whole market says yeah you're
right but Simona DS says that it is and
when you get here about the Smarties
back Simona DS was a sort of popular
writer at the time so think about what
that Oprah says or you know President
Obama says or Rush Limbaugh says so
imagine somebody with that sort of
currency saying but this does sound like
a good definition so Socrates says okay
we have to think about this some of the
big heavy inner things that this is okay
let's think about this so he says you
said the repayments of the debt of
Justin Singh so he appears to me to be
right yeah Socrates says Simona tease
after the manner of poets an ordinary
person who's trying to you know compose
something what seem to have spoken
darkly of the nature of Justice what he
really meant to say we're gonna talk
about paying your debts is giving people
that's that's a good understanding of
justice right that's sort of our
ordinary consumption you guys came up
with that at the start of the class
didn't you giving people what they
deserve when you've gotten angry in the
past because you think somebody is wrong
you they didn't give you what you
deserve you are appealing to this sense
of justice there's something to this
isn't
what do you deserve at the end of the
semester there really you know get home
example should I go home and you know if
we're gonna use great book so you're in
the little smelly grades just assign
crates randomly how many of you would
like that I assign grades randomly I'll
say we'll divide it up across the board
we have 25 students five days five days
five seats five DS find us Google who
wants to tissue for that one
let's let's make it a chancer
let's do 12 days one seed 12 betting
person
what if I up the stakes what if I said
50 nays tennis 60% chance you're right
how this doesn't always win how would
you feel about let's say you did get a
name let's say we don't mind along with
that you got the name would you feel
you're anything let's say in a great
book you didn't actually have a widget
how would you do it again if there's
ever an instrument to be very this is
this is we shouldn't have done this in
the first place I don't know whose idea
this was right
that's what would come up these thought
exercise are kind of good for making
sense
what do you think what about if I do it
on the basis of who I like now maybe
some students will come to office hours
and it makes chance with them they get a
name other students I really don't
methanol efficiency that fair no yeah
using another criteria I'm not just like
you know reaching into a half but I'm
using the criteria that that isn't fair
my own personal preferences so how
should I
that's a good way to put it based on the
quality and after you know this is stuff
you'll be able to check it but in great
part which is kind of nice when I was a
student that tells you what you deserve
what makes you deserve a grade is the
quality and the effort of your work
right that's what means you deserve it
right now nobody's deserving of anything
really sure they have teacher
evaluations at the end of the semester
right and your guys are going to
evaluate meaning I haven't earned any
sort of evaluation and really three
weeks of the class we haven't really
reached the point where we deserve we do
deserve some things I deserve respect
from the music you deserve respect for
me you know you deserve a teacher who
shows up on time was prepared who has
read the tax I deserve students who do
the same right now you know we've got a
good good sort of before going about
don't Lee but that's because we're
working with we all have expectations
about what we deserve so maybe that's
enough for justice Socrates doesn't
think so
Socrates starts asking all these
questions and starts asking questions
about friends and enemies how many of
you collect what are your friends
deserve from here
loyalty all these other things - she's
not here for an answer cheat on them
tell them you know steal their things
kidnapped kidnapped for kids kidnap the
parents all sorts of things shouldn't do
to the friends all right
teller
boy or girl friend that they're cheating
out there not one of the gravities this
may be a little bit harder to relate to
who's we don't tend to think in our
culture too much in terms of friends and
enemies although we actually have that
that term has been coined in front of me
that been used a bit this is a friend
somebody who you're close with may
actually turns out to be an enemy and
what makes them an enemy they're trying
to undercut you they're trying to
undermine you you may have gone this
tends to be an issue more in women
circles than in meta circles
came up because the the warfare between
women is often much more subtle and much
more intense and involved than it is for
a preventive boys because men and boys
going to be a little bit you know less
on the ball when it comes to figuring
out who their friends and who their
enemies really are a little less on the
ball when it comes to confronting them
we tend to men tend to be a little bit
more naive about these five down you
know even still today though he moves
that are made in conversations and I'll
talk with some of my female friends or
my fiance about what took place so no
better cousins a really nice time well
you don't realize what that person was
actually saying you know they were
actually you know making a move of one
so really I didn't know that well people
who intend to do you harm or who are
doing you harm
what do they deserve
I'm feeling something try sir
yeah
I mean it's so hard because you want to
do the same thing back yeah you're
getting into the sort of paradox that
Socrates is bringing out
seems like enemies deserve to be treated
badly because their enemies right and at
the same time is that the right thing to
do that's where one of these problems
with the conventional notion of justice
is just doing what the people deserve it
was going to come on that doesn't mean
that it is totally off the charts
yeah or anything like that it just means
that's not enough to get us but what are
you going to say good yeah why yeah same
thing also something along the lines of
you should be nice to them where you
should treat them well because it's
going to be like keeping hot keeping hot
coals on their head some of these words
mixed up it's gonna make them feel
really bad unless they just keep taking
and treating you badly so you know this
is something that that's part of our
human nature this is a normal response
your normal response to somebody wrong
in it is to be angry at them you get
angry because you feel and song sinners
hurt and put down or something like that
all of you get angry your aim your
response is a sign of something to do
with justice you could be mistaken about
it you know we sometimes go off to too
easily you get angry about things we
shouldn't get angry about miss Reba
- saying to us for doing but when you
get angry it's because you feel that the
song injustice has been done it's you
know it's here it's actually part of
your your body's normal response you get
ready to fight the things there's other
responses you need to depress you can
feel sad turn bitter you know this is
this is going to be a problematic view
let's look at the next which is through
semanas might makes right through suma
kisses posing a much more difficult
problem and I haven't gotten yet to
uploading the things for these
problematic will all approaches there's
a couple different isms
that we're going to talk about walking
on through the semester terse images
represent some of those isms there's
something we call relativism any of you
guys heard this term before relativism
maybe in a sociology or anthropology
class or an intro class doesn't ring a
bell
relativism is the notion that truth or
values really don't have any sort of
objective basis they are relative either
to the individual or the groups or the
society but the one way of thinking
about it is what's what's wrong for me
as a wrong for you maybe because I'm
from a different
social role than you are let's say you
know we think about cultures whether
some things that are considered wrong in
our culture that are not considered
wrong in other cultures
then you have to think of lava right you
can think of some things that are
considered wrong in other cultures that
are okay in this culture and I don't
think about clothing in various Muslim
countries where the not necessarily the
government or the majority of the people
are Muslim in most of those countries
women Vegas is regulated you know
because of religious rules right and in
some cases they just wear at a job
offense part in others you can see
people actually clap from head to toe do
you know reasoning does anyone know why
women are supposed to conceal parts of
their their body to prevent that from
being hostile there's some sort of moral
reasoning behind it do we do we follow
that as f is that the way our society
tends to look at it put aside to know
rape cases where people say yeah she
dressed like a hooker so therefore she
think about ordinary life do we say well
I think about all the women in the class
the only going to people actually
inherent with covered there there are
two minutes one is wearing a baseball
cap one's wearing a hoodie all the women
in here by the standards of say Saudi
Arabia are provoking men to act on lost
they are transgressing against you know
the very structure of the universe do we
feel that way
well maybe over in Saudi Arabia that's
true and it's it's false over here so
maybe it's good over there and then it's
bad over here that make sense does
really do you think that through it is
one thing to say that that's the way
they feel about it and that's the way we
feel does it really make sense to say
it's it's actually true that it's good
over there for women to be covered from
head to toe mean it's it's bad to
require women to do that there's some
problems with that
that's relativism another really
problematic thing I don't have an ism
for it is this whole notion of might
makes right whoever holds the cards
whoever holds the power gets to decide
what becomes writing and writing wrong
is merely doing what you know people in
in charge with people who have power the
people who can purchase think is good
and doing wrong is doing what they think
it's bad another problematic thing that
fits in with this is what we'll call the
egoism and egoism is this notion that
really all good and be ideas is what
satisfies honor our desires
appear it's going to be evaluated
differently from different individuals
so it satisfies my desires what I have
to do is just what's good for me
it's a matter of fact if I can get
things out of you like let's say I could
charge you let's say I start charging
through grades you know from an egoist
perspective if I wasn't going to get
caught that'd be a great thing to do it
would be so good from your perspective
would it it might be actually you know
depending on what the cost was
today for an a or something would be a
matter of negotiation would that really
be right though could could right and
wrong will just be a matter of finding
the balance point between how it feels
for you and how it feels for me it's not
going to work
yes some of worthless Emma kisses ideas
are going to have so what's this
actually look at some of the things that
Drusilla it says through semuc it says
that justice is the interest of the
stronger but Socrates tries to make it
clarified do you mean stronger like you
know the bigger guy would be the biggest
person who's probably the strongest
person in here who's a memorials
and it's probably between you two guys
with that because the whole secret thing
so the interest of the stronger that way
you guys need to be the king and tell
everyone what to do that doing what you
say it's good sock you says is that what
you mean through something that says
come on you know that's not like here's
what I actually mean every place has
somebody in charge right they're the
strong who's in charge is your hustle
when you go back home
and tell them somebody hold it there
right
sometimes I said this is my house my
rules right
anybody you know who's in charge there
the stronger when you have it your own
house you get to be the stronger you get
to do anything you want there's a
comedian who talks about you know having
this data over investing with his dance
I like leaving the door open and the
air-conditioning and say I am going to
eat the whole outside cause it's my
house and when you start paying for it
then you get to decide but you're not
paying this power bill so you know I'm
not gonna say big baller but he's listen
up sometimes like you know something bad
because apparently was really angry at
Stanford that sort of thing but what was
going on there
damn is in charge what about it in our
society who's in charge
you don't think about the classroom you
guys are sort of drilled into I'm the
professor you're the students we
actually try to cultivate something to
get you out of that to get your
conversation going and make you feel as
if you own the class someone but even
the professors who encourage all this
it's a form a big circle and you're
feeling sorry and that sort of thing
however they wouldn't want to push comes
to shove does that does that always
stand up in your experience have any
professors like they're in charge right
who else is in charge Bureau it kind of
sucks being sued there's so many people
in charge of the unit
let's get better as you get older who
else is in charge of it you have a coach
the coach makes and do things right
gifted I'm yours undergo some sacrifices
over you know whether you get to go home
for Christmas or things like that that's
somebody who's stronger have income the
coach says you have to do that therefore
it's a good thing to do who else is in
charge of it try to paint it all these
government authorities right the cop
down the street he tells me I can't go
park here I can't go park there it's
also going to have to you know pull my
car off and go through a checkpoint what
happened
they got an eternal go the other way
people do that sometimes
oh they'll chase you down especially in
you know this 911 those are the more
powerful through Semak is is saying
whatever is in the interest of the more
so is that everything that the powerful
tell you you becomes good because of
that it's not just what they tell you to
do what is it me interest what they want
what they desire what they're looking
for
that's what's good and what goes against
that is what's been more unjust justice
is just people doing what the stronger
want them to do so you know think about
it we're a very powerful nation army we
spend more on our military than
everybody else combined we went into
Iraq and Iraq has a lot of oil don't
they and when the Iraq war ii first
started people were saying we're going
to war take it away
to do that we by that a while we didn't
take it we probably should just take it
shouldn't win but we're stronger they
don't like it we can kill them they
wanted his nest they should can audition
know that the stronger person gets to
decide what counts
wrong again this is through civic assist
veto now are there any problems with
this think of any problems of Socrates
races
that's a strong possibility but they say
could be morally wrong so something
would be both right in what sense and
long in another sense that gets kind of
confusing doesn't it so it's not
entirely right if they're summing this
word right then that shouldn't be
possible where you shouldn't have any
Socrates says another thing too you know
the interest of the stronger the
stronger always know what's really in
their interest do they always make the
right determinations about what the good
thing for them will be let's say that it
was that we have something like a
kingship let's say the king was really
into drinking long time people like to
drink you know there's a reason why it's
all so much liquor and wine the beer
drinking because it's fun to drink if
you do enough of a head after a while
it's no longer just fun it's something
you need to do classy
I said let's say the king the king is a
drunk now the king wants to drink all
the time he's stronger is you supplying
him with with as much drink as he wants
actually the trend but he thinks it is
so then you would have to go against his
his requirements in order to do what he
really needs with you yeah in one way
what you from pursuing his position what
you would they do it would be unjust
wouldn't it be wrong in another way it
would be right again it's kind of
confusing mr. it becomes very difficult
to decide do people want me to know it's
what's best for them do you think most
people know most of the time what's best
for them where do we make that decision
I know hey stuff I'm 40 years old I'm
gonna workaholic was that
one of the work hard
maybe that workaholic wait for a
girlfriend
what's a workaholic
they don't balance work which is a value
we talked about that early on and all
these other values they get work to have
a priority I learned it from my dad my
dad was a tax attorney and during tax
season we didn't see him for four months
because he would go to the office before
you woke up and come back from the
office after we went to see and you work
like a dog and then on the weekends he
hang out those kids it was great but I
learned a way of doing things in a way
of living that I'm still trying to
figure out now am I really in touch with
what's good for me intellectually I am
but if I am a workaholic have I
integrated that intellectual knowledge
with how I actually live do they know I
feel terrible about the fact that I I
don't have everything not did I learn
for you as I had planned to as I
actually had my to-do list because
there's something I really should be
obsessing about what do you think yes or
no how many think you shut up that
should be awesome
Ida sure nobody didn't open a do you
think I shouldn't be taking that stuff
too seriously
well how many are undecided that's a met
song let's say I'm the one who's in
charge now I'm the king
do I actually understand the structure
of my desires and what's good for me
this is stuff we're gonna explore the
entire semester we you can't assume that
the people who just have power know what
the the right thing is another thing
that Socrates brings up with your
semanas is it really the case for
something it says that those who are in
charge to exploit the beaker stronger
just take the weaker and impose their
will on them and that's what justice is
is that always the case
that is the case in some cases isn't it
how many of you have ever been in a
relationship where you felt explained
yes no somebody was taking advantage of
you because they could not talkative
professor take advantage of students
actually yeah I'm not just talking about
you know having affairs or stuff they
make students do all sorts of research
for them and then they incorporate the
research into their own writings that is
that fair is that just
but according to through sickness that
would be just fine wouldn't the people
who are in charge the politicians who
make them great you know rules they can
set up the rules to favor themselves
can't they
you know if you go into politics here
and in our society it's very difficult
to rise I don't know what it's like out
here in New York I come from the Chicago
area if you become a politician in
Chicago you cannot rise without becoming
corrupt you can't get promoted within
the parties you can't get things done
without you know breaking some people's
wheels and favoring other people if true
Simic is right that's a-ok
you know I think it says the Shepherd or
doesn't fatten the Machine you know
because because it's good for the Sheep
does he the shepherd was fat in the
shoots that could kill me you know
there's actually a old saying about
democracy democracy is tools and the
lamb sitting down to dinner who are the
wolves and that you know little Anna and
the wolves are the other two people who
actually have some power who are going
to you know trying to get you to vote
for them so there are
right there and specific it's a saying
all relationships are like that Socrates
says no that's not the case it uses
doctors as an example all right any of
you thinking about going to law school
eventually of medical school or other
professional schools now you make more
money when you do that right you will
you will get something for people is
that why you're going into it to them to
make make a killing especially that big
see the states because doctors have to
take on massive right first three years
of paying why are you doing it what's
the point of the medical art is to make
money is it's a whole power over people
some doctors do that don't they
so I'm not going to get on the kick of
playing God but it's in the norm is that
what the is that what the art as he says
is that what that is it's about the
skill what is it about what we'll put
aside blog or something or at least with
medicine what's the point in going to
the doctor what was the doctor's
function yeah
to make people better we have a
preventive medicine you know preventing
disease and then also time people the
doctors not because they're very
competitive medicine
I don't have a bad one for this to
myself I don't go to the doctor unless I
am what sick ok I get sinus infection
now I have to find a doctor is a doctor
really just there to make money off of
me or is he there to heal me the better
a doctor he is the more ease about
healing
isn't it what about government what
about holding power over is the goal of
that really just to wait them as much as
possible there are politicians who when
people there they're always building is
that why people get into politics is
that what the heart of ruling is about
what is it what is it supposed to be
about
very good that's very well expressed
that is Socrates position those who are
ruling if they're really truly rulers is
doing what the heart is about they are
taking into account those who are under
the leader and there they're supposed to
do what's best for them
not just what's best for themselves and
they probably won't actually profit very
much you know anytime that you're in
charge of other people if you actually
care about those other people it's a lot
of work and a lot of hassle and usually
they're not happy with what you do
anyway but that's the point of some
politicians let's think about what the
world would be like if through Senecas
right what kind of world would you what
should your practical reason you use
this word practical reasoning people
option what should you do this is where
I want to leave it
let's think might really doesn't make
right there are no know situations where
a doctor isn't afraid to become a good
doctor where a politician is training to
actually manage people well let's say
it's all about exploitation what
there's money as possible okay let's put
it into the broader terms money the
money by to influence and power shall
make as much money
powerful and what do you have to do it
early to do that a lot of bling you got
to find out who's actually got power and
then suck up to them make them as happy
as possible so that they will bring you
in and then once you're in charge what
are you gonna do
stick it to everybody else benefit you
should be the you know biggest thief you
could possibly be because once you're in
charge okay it's anything goes you can
indulge your desires whether they're
good desires bad desires and that's
justice what should you do if you if you
are not able to apply some layout and
you'd better what
do you want to be a just person how
should you have let's just make the
assumption this is a bad assumptions I'm
hoping that all of you are gonna rise in
society that none of you are analyzing
society and society really is just this
dog-eat-dog exploiting everybody else
sort of the situation how should you
begin
yeah
we're even to reach pensions yeah that's
an attempt to try to gain power if you
can't you should just you know be as
humble as you can possibly be
and let the you know the rich the
powerful popular do whatever they want
to do and help them out you know you get
to marry into a rich family by meeting
rich people first and sucking up to them
and hanging out with them and being
there yes ma'am yeah I mean I'll say
you're right yeah and maybe facilitating
all of the things if they if they want
drugs help me get drums you know it
would be a good thing to do it according
to some penis so we were seeing what the
theory actually looks like notice that's
not in the textbook listen that's not in
order
what we were reading that's something
that we're going beyond and reading into
those those are the implications of it
practically feasible we're going to look
at this again something similar with
what's called the ring of guidance from
next class
Socrates demolishes through sickness or
something is this going to quit talking
the Adam Ant Istanbul Marcus and Glaucon
are going to make the profit even I like
you so we're going to pick up with
ethics laughs I'll see all of you there
is back